une nouvelle étude de l'université
columbia démontre que des enfants
exposés à un certain type de polluants
urbains lorsqu'il était dans le ventre
de leur mère sont plus à risque de
développer des problèmes de comportement
donc c'était de dépression et
d'attention mont-saint-michel laisse
penser là ce sont surtout les femmes
enceintes qui doit faire attention
oui absolument en fait c'est pas la
première étude que columbia fait sur ce
sujet là en fait ce qu'ils font c'est
qui le mesure en prenant les prises de
sang des polluants dans ce cas si
c'était dh
ap donc des hydrocarbures aromatiques
polycycliques ça semble bien compliqué
mais c'est le résultat de finalement la
combustion de l'essence donc les
voitures le charbon le bois
même le tabac produits ça alors ce qu'on
a fait c'est qu'on a pris des prises de
sang chez ses fans là et ensuite on a
suivi les enfants 3 ans 5 en septembre
jusqu'à 11 ans on a fait des tests
psychologiques
qu'est-ce qu'on a découvert c'est que
plus il ya de à chapet plus on voit des
problèmes en psychologie que l'on
appelle d'auto régulation qu'est ce que
c'est c'est qu'ils ont des difficultés
ces jeunes là avec leurs idées avec
leurs émotions avec leurs actions quand
on est fan le comportement ça peut
manière des problèmes à l'adolescence
regardons ensemble des risques pour
quelque chose de plus sérieux
alors on parle de troubles obsessionnels
compulsifs les toques l'été délai atdh
pardon les troupes du déficit de
l'attention et les abus de substances
l'alcool les drogues donc sont à risque
pour ça alors comment expliquer qu'il
ait une exposition avant la naissance
qui puisse avoir comme ça d
des effets sur directement sur l'enfant
cet équipement a réussi à démontrer que
ces fameux polluants la rendant le
placenta vont dans le foetus
ils vont même dans le code génétique il
se colle à l'adn de l'enfant dont quand
il grandit il y aurait fort probablement
des changements dans le développement
des neurones qui les met à beaucoup plus
vulnérable face à ces à ses problèmes de
comportement là et à cette étude mais
c'est pas la première étude à faire ce
lien alors absolument pas céline on en a
parlé ensemble l'an dernier où ont
démontré également des problèmes
d'anxiété d'attention chez ces enfants
là il faut dire qu'il ya d'autres
facteurs en génétique l'environnement
social et familial est également un
facteur de risque fort fort important
est bon nous ici à montréal ont produit
en hiver beaucoup de à chapet de 4 8
fois plus que durant l'été à cause de
nos célèbres foyers au bois que l'on
adore mais qui malheureusement un cause
beaucoup de à chapeau c'est pas
seulement dans certains pays surtout
dans nos pensées au charbon la chine etc
non nous sommes peu touchés ou et mis en
règlement municipal à montréal en 2018
on devrait on devrait cesser cette
pratique la mort